[Música]
aquí comienza ella es hoy el programa
feminista de France 24 este 30 de abril
de Paraguay vota en elecciones generales
las presidenciales abarcarán por
supuesto el destino de una nación que
además es joven en democracia y
profundamente conservadora en ese camino
este año las mujeres podrían verse muy
perjudicadas en participación política
dificultando el camino a los movimientos
de mujeres que luchan por la igualdad de
derechos en un escenario político que
está dominado por hombres solo hay una
candidata en la carrera presidencial y
es el número dos de Efraín alegre el
líder de la oposición que se enfrenta a
Santiago peña del partido Colorado vamos
a ver el informe de Valeria sacone de
Amine guidara y de Flavia Borja por el
tema la inundación y no pero
doña Cómo estás Johanna es candidata del
partido país solidario empezó su carrera
política desde el activismo estudiantil
contamos contigo
hoy esta joven progresista visite el
barrio de los bañados una de las
regiones más pobres de Asunción aquí el
60% de la población tiene menos de 30
años estamos haciendo campaña
recordándole a la gente tres cosas
primero la fecha de la elección segundo
la importancia del cambio y por último
nuestras opciones electorales pues
tenemos un sistema electoral que ahora
con opciones preferentes de Voto para
los comicios del 30 de abril un tercio
de los 9.095 candidatos son mujeres
muchos analistas coinciden en que la
vuelta la fiesta cerradas puede
perjudicar la escasa representatividad
de las mujeres que es la más baja de la
región con un 20% de cargos electos lo
que pasa es que el problema principal
mujeres Es la falta de financiamiento y
entramos en un esquema de listas con
votos preferentes donde cada campaña es
individual cada campaña tiene que tener
su propio equipo su propio
financiamiento su propio programa y cada
uno tiene que ir a buscar el
financiamiento de campaña y a las
mujeres eso le afecta el doble
por eso las mujeres están cada vez más
organizadas como demuestra este acto
electoral planificado por las candidatas
de la concertación la alianza de
partidos que espera rebasar el poder a
los Colorados hoy en un encuentro que
está hecho para nosotras esta socióloga
destaca que las paraguayas tienen una
larga trayectoria de resistencia que
aumentó Durante los años de la dictadura
militar a pesar de eso no consiguen
alcanzar posiciones de Liderazgo Nunca
tuvimos una mujer presidenta Nunca
tuvimos una mujer presidenta del
Congreso tampoco
y esto tiene que ver también con que
cuando nosotras obtuvimos el derecho al
voto nos relacionamos esto con la
posibilidad de ser electas Paraguay es
un país profundamente machista entonces
hay un cambio cultural que se debe dar
para que esa ese empoderamiento se
traduzca efectivamente en participación
política de las mujeres y que estén
ocupando cargos de representación
política desde la guerra grande las
paraguayas fueron cruciales en la
recuperación de su país hoy no se
resignan a tener un papel subalterno
para conversar sobre la lucha por la
paridad en Paraguay y se conectan con
ellas hoy la doctora Lilian Soto quien
es médica máster en administración
pública fue concejal de Asunción y
además también fue ministra secretaria
de la función pública de Paraguay Ella
es adicionalmente una investigadora un
especialista en asuntos de género y
también está en ella soy Marcela
subcenteno quien es abogada con maestría
en derechos humanos y tiene varios
posgrados en temas de género y derechos
de las mujeres y trabaja en temas
electorales principalmente en
participación política esto desde hace
más de 10 años además integrando la
asociación feminista cuña roja Muchas
gracias a ambas y voy a comenzar con
Lilian en Paraguay la lucha por los
derechos de las mujeres tiene una
particularidad no y es existir en un
país que tiene probablemente la mayor
proporción de Católicos en la región y
esto afecta la forma en la que la gente
vive la gente de la forma en que la
gente vota Y por supuesto en la forma en
que se legisla Así que cuál es el de
estas características en estas
elecciones
No creo que acá tenemos dos aspectos que
son interesantes este con esta pregunta
que estás realizando Por una parte hace
unos años hicimos una investigación
sobre las motivaciones de las mujeres y
las cuestiones que las impulsan actuar
en política y Cómo afecta la política a
las mujeres y uno de los elementos
centrales este que apareció fue la
militancia religiosa por ejemplo desde
muchas mujeres empiezan con militancias
en grupos religiosos que las van
colocando como ante situaciones sociales
que este les eran ajenas antes de esa
militancia entonces puede ser un
elemento interesante en términos de El
catolicismo y sobre todo en tiempos
anteriores cuando la teología de la
liberación Es la importante en Paraguay
este que esto haya impulsado a mujeres a
ejercer liderazgos entonces son espacios
de militancia de las mujeres ahora hoy
tenemos una avanzada anti derechos muy
importante que están claros muy
fuertemente en los grupos religiosos no
solamente el católico sino con la
penetración de las iglesias evangélicas
en las comunidades también estos grupos
evangélicos están teniendo un impacto
muy fuerte en todo lo que hace a el
pensamiento comunitario entonces a
partir de ahí sí creo que esta avanzada
anti derecho que como decías tan Clama
muy fuertemente en los grupos religiosos
con mucha Claridad están colocando
obstáculos a lo que hace la
participación política de las mujeres
Marcela en un país de corte conservador
tan dominante Cuáles son los retos que
usted ve en luchas específicas Como por
ejemplo en los derechos reproductivos en
el caso del aborto por ejemplo llueve en
las críticas internacionales y solamente
está permitido cuando peligra la vida de
la madre
Bueno la verdad es que son temas que
tenemos que decirlo están ausentes del
debate político electoral en este
momento hay un se ve la presencia de
mujeres y los discursos
feministas y de Derechos Humanos casi
como una amenaza para el estatus quo y
para la campaña electoral eh Como decía
Lilian tiene que ver con la vuelta de
las mujeres a esos roles tradicionales y
estos discursos encuentran nichos dentro
de los propios partidos políticos que
silencian amenazan coartan la voz de las
mujeres Entonces hay temas que están
ausentes de la campaña como es este el
tema de los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos donde Paraguay tiene
efectivamente una ley muy restrictiva y
donde se tiene que revisar y esto tiene
que pasar por un congreso por el nuevo
congreso que se conforme y sabemos de
que este congreso puede llegar a ser muy
conservador y así como también otros
temas que están en el debate y se vienen
poniendo desde hace ya algún tiempo que
tiene que ver con la ley de paridad o
sea el porcentaje de mujeres en la
presencia de mujeres en espacios de toma
de decisión en espacios electivos Va a
continuar siendo baja comparada con los
países de la región si no se establecen
mecanismos efectivos para garantizar la
participación de las mujeres en igualdad
de condiciones con los hombres hoy no
existen esas esas condiciones y bueno
son temas que deberían de poder tratarse
dentro del próximo congreso Bueno pero
entonces aquí lo que hay es una lucha
doble línea primero por las pocas
mujeres en los órganos de poder porque
esto genera muchas discrepancias en la
democracia no una democracia sana
necesita tener la representación de
todos sus ciudadanos y pues bueno
segundos y la representación de las
mujeres no llega ni siquiera al 20% Esto
va a generar evidentemente unos
problemas de generación de política
pública feminista y evidentemente pues
aquí lo que le quiero preguntar es desde
donde se dará esta lucha porque
ciertamente no va a ser en el congreso
en estas
Bueno lo primero que que hay que decir
ahí Es que la lucha de las mujeres en
Paraguay la lucha feminista siempre se
desarrolló desde los márgenes del estado
y las conquistas fueron a pesar de las
fuertes alianzas entre los sectores
conservadores y el poder político nada
de lo que las mujeres hemos conseguido
en Paraguay ha sido desde el poder ha
sido desde la lucha en realidad desde la
resistencia desde todo lo que significó
generar información ni siquiera
información teníamos en Paraguay en
términos de las brechas de género y han
sido los movimientos sociales los
organismos no gubernamentales con sus
centros de investigación feministas los
que han producido los primeros datos en
Paraguay respecto de brechas Y a partir
de ahí Se han generado una serie de
digamos movimientos que consiguieron
todos los logros que hemos tenido si hoy
tenemos un Ministerio de la mujer es
porque el movimiento de mujeres ha
luchado durante mucho tiempo para crear
esa
sostenerla y pese a sus dificultades
sigue insistiendo si tenemos una ley
contra la violencia hacia las mujeres
también si tenemos derechos civiles
derechos este políticos no nada de esto
ha sido desde el poder político entonces
decías vos qué desde dónde pues desde
ese lugar desde la resistencia desde la
movilización desde seguir impulsando que
las mujeres se presenten si bien Hoy es
cierto que tenemos un estancamiento Y
tenemos incluso disminución de
candidaturas hay una presencia fuerte de
mujeres necesitamos además que esas
mujeres tengan conciencia de género
necesitamos que las mujeres claramente
desafíen a el pensamiento patriarcal
dentro de sus partidos políticos porque
hay que entender que una cultura
machista y patriarcal no afecta
solamente a los hombres es decir eso
impactan toda la sociedad y a veces las
mujeres reproducen también todos esos
elementos entonces hay mucha lucha que
hacer esa lucha se da desde el
movimiento feminista desde los
feminismos desde las organizaciones de
mujeres y creo que así seguirá este
vamos a tener seguramente las alianzas
en el poder político que nos posibiliten
colocar algunos temas no como los
quisiéramos pero sí vamos a llevar
adelante todos estos procesos que nos
permitan seguir avanzando miren ya nos
quedamos en tiempo pero antes Una última
pregunta que le quiero hacer Marcela Y
es que nos ha contado nuestra reportera
en Paraguay que a varios grupos de lucha
de derechos les incomoda que se utilice
para referirse a ellos la palabra
feminismo ellos prefieren hablar o ellas
más bien prefieren hablar de lucha de
derechos y de progresismo ustedes se
sienten cómodas Y por qué
Bueno
yo creo que sí ahí hay espacios
políticos que están asumiendo la palabra
feminismo de hecho hay un grupo por
ejemplo dentro del partido liberal que
es feministas liberales que fueron las
que dieron la batalla interna y lograron
también reunir a todas las mujeres del
partido para reformar Los estatutos
partidarios Y lograr la paridad O sea
ahí vemos una posición política desde
las desde un colectivo feminista dentro
de un partido político que se reconoce y
se nombra feminista De hecho hay otros
otros grupos otras otros partidos que
cuentan con movimientos feminista o con
feministas que integran eh los
movimientos pero el costo político puede
llegar a ser muy alto cuando se
reivindican como feministas verdad
dentro del dentro de la dentro del de
Dentro de este ámbito partidario y y
creo que tiene que ver con esa
con esa con esa lucha constante que hay
que tienen que estar representando su su
banca o su candidatura y al mismo tiempo
encuentran como otro frente que tiene
que ver con la identificación feminista
entonces este se hace como más difícil
por lo que observamos acá en las mujeres
muchas se reconocen feministas pero les
cuesta mucho más salir con esa voz
pública hace el feminismo porque sienten
que puede ser algo que les pueda restar
votos finalmente en las contiendas
electorales porque justamente no se
entiende es que el feminismo y también
porque obviamente se busca en las
mujeres esos roles tradicionales o que
no tengan una una mirada o una
perspectiva de género o se busca mujeres
que sean sumisa a esos poderes que están
dentro de los movimientos y de las
listas pero creo que algo que se está
transformando Yo creo que hoy en estas
elecciones sí lo vemos con más claridad
los posicionamientos de algunas mujeres
que sí están
poniéndose desde ese rol feminista como
candidatas
pues son Lilian Soto y Marcela
subcentino gracias a las dos por
entregarnos un panorama más amplio de lo
que significa la política y la paridad
en Paraguay y a nuestros televidentes
como siempre un agradecimiento por
vernos nos vemos Próximamente en ellas
hoy y también en France 24
[Música]